wow
[Musica]
[Applauso]
no no
[Musica]
[Applauso]
siamo tutti colpevoli
sì siamo tutti colpevoli di scarsa
sostenibilità
quando compriamo questi prodotti e li
paghiamo a prezzi troppo bassi quando
non vogliamo spendere e magari
pretendiamo anche che siano di buona
qualità
mentre ci gustiamo la vista guardando
questo bel banco di prodotti
ortofrutticoli
parliamo spendiamo due parole sul
concetto di sostenibilità concetto
attuale
bellissimo importantissimo ma che
talvolta viene anche frainteso
utilizzato a sproposito oppure viene
anche idealizzato fino a renderlo una
chimera un'illusione che molti inseguono
ma che in pochi riescono realmente a
riconoscere e ad identificare una
commissione delle nazioni unite sullo
sviluppo e sull'ambiente ha definito lo
sviluppo sostenibile come lo sviluppo
che soddisfa i bisogni del presente
senza compromettere le capacità delle
future generazioni di soddisfare i
propri bellissima definizione quasi
poetica oserei dire ma siamo onesti non
è che ci spieghi molto della
sostenibilità ci faccia capire molto
della sostenibilità addirittura qualche
volta ci porta anche un po fuori strada
perché molto spesso quando parliamo di
sostenibilità
il pensiero di molte persone va
direttamente ed esclusivamente
all'aspetto ambientale e non dobbiamo
inchinare al dobbiamo preservare il
nostro paese il nostro pianeta non
dobbiamo consumare tutte le risorse
giusta tutti aspetti importantissimi ma
che danno solo una descrizione
parziale e sommaria di quello che è il
concetto di sostenibilità
nel parlare di sostenibilità infatti
bisogna prendere in considerazione tre
aspetti diversi quello ambientale
ovviamente importante ma anche quello
sociale e l'aspetto economico
soltanto quando questi tre aspetti sono
presenti contemporaneamente in
sovrapposizione
all'interno di un'azienda e del prodotto
che nasce allora possiamo parlare di
sostenibilità
se invece una di queste dimensioni
manca e non si realizza il nostro
prodotto potrà essere equo se manca la
componente ambientale potremmo definirlo
realizzabile se dovesse mancare la
componente sociale o al limite avremmo
un'azienda o un prodotto vivibile se
manca la componente economica ma in ogni
caso non potremmo definire la nostra
azienda i nostri prodotti sostenibili
completamente tutti noi il consumatore
deve farsi carico di chiedere alle
aziende cui fa riferimento o di cercare
nei prodotti che va a comprare che
queste componenti siano tutte sempre
presenti anche se con peso in maniera
diversa
se però dal punto di vista ambientale o
dal punto di vista sociale il
consumatore può fare relativamente po
poco se non chiedere pretendere che
queste componenti ci siano dal punto di
vista economico
il consumatore deve farsi parte attiva
deve essere in grado di riconoscere la
sostenibilità ma anche di pagare il
prezzo giusto farsi carico di quello che
è il costo della sostenibilità
quindi tornando all'inizio di questa
specie quando non paghiamo un prezzo
adeguato quando previa paghiamo prezzi
imbarazzanti come riportato a questo
articolo siamo tutti colpevoli siamo
colpevoli di scarsa sostenibilità
spendiamo adesso due parole
sulla qualità due parole io insegno un
corso di 64 ore sulla qualità dei
prodotti orticoli tranquilli in cinque
minuti ce la caviamo non vi tengo qui
fino al mese prossimo una buona
definizione di qualità è l'insieme di
caratteristiche che soddisfa determinate
esigenze
implicito in questa definizione è che
per parlare di qualità dobbiamo tenere
in debito conto sia il prodotto che
prendiamo in considerazione sia
l'utilizzatore all utilizzo che facciamo
di quel prodotto per cui potremmo
definire una qualità per esempio
prendendo in considerazione le esigenze
il punto di vista del produttore oppure
un certo tipo di qualità mettendoci dal
punto di vista dell'industria di
trasformazione
ovviamente oggigiorno in questo contesto
in un'ottica di filiera
il punto di vista le esigenze che ci
interessa maggiormente prendere in
considerazioni sono quelle del
consumatore un consumatore per esempio
potrebbe apprezzare particolarmente un
pomodoro come questo solo perché è bello
lucido molto gustoso
e proprio gustoso buono oppure potrebbe
prendere in considerazioni come prodotto
di qualità anche questo bel cespo di
radicchio di chioggia solo perché è ben
informato ha un colore brillante ma
anche perché è pieno di sostanze
antiossidanti che fanno bene alla salute
ancora potremmo avere scusate sto
dicendo il potere però il mostro di
pomodoro questi asparagi perché proprio
non tutti sanno hanno elevatissimo
contenuto di calcio al limite quasi
superiore a quello del latte vaccino
ancora un peperone
semplicemente perché ha più vitamina c
della spremuta d'arancio
sempre più spesso e sempre più persone
considerano come prodotti di qualità non
soltanto questo non lo trovate al
supermercato a portarvelo ma questo bel
melone non solo per il colore
profumo ma anche perché magari è stato
fatto senza utilizzare prodotti chimici
o usandone molto pochi
potremmo andare avanti con esempi è
ancora lunga però terni un attimo
abbiamo appena accettato nessuno si è
offeso quando ha detto che questo è un
prodotto di qualità perché è stato fatto
utilizzando pochi prodotti chimici
rispettando l'ambiente però se ci
pensate è anche un prodotto sostenibile
perché non ho usato prodotti chimici e
ho rispettato un ambiente quindi di pari
passo i due aspetti vanno abbastanza
insieme qualità dei prodotti e
sostenibilità dei prodotti
infatti quando voi andate a chiedere
pretendete di comprare di acquistare dei
prodotti di alta qualità state sicuri
che è stata e sostenendo spingendo e
aumentando anche la sostenibilità delle
aziende agricole torniamo un attimo
indietro però a quei prodotti ottenuti
senza l'utilizzo di composti chimici
le malerbe si usano gli erbicidi
prodotti chimici però le malerbe anche
se non vogliamo crescono vengono
sull'agricoltore deve gestirla in
qualche maniera se la decisione
rispettare l'ambiente non uso prodotti
chimici dovrò assumere più persone ma
devo pagare in maniera adeguata perché
sono sostenibili dal punto di vista
sociale oppure posso fare un qualcosa
che si chiama pacciamatura la vedete qui
copro terreno con un tessuto un qualcosa
di colore nero che non fa sviluppare le
mani le malerbe se invece che usare
plastica di derivazione petrolio poi uso
amido di mais ancora meglio sto
chiudendo il ciclo a punto di vista
ambientale ma tutte queste tecniche
costano costano molto di più di un
trattamento diserbante qualcuno di voi
consuma prodotti
biologici probabilmente vi sarà capitato
per difendere quei prodotti
dagli attacchi degli insetti
io posso usare un insetticida se sono in
regime di coltura biologica
l'insetticida non lo posso utilizzare
posso mettere in atto tutta una serie di
altre strategie
rilasci insetti utili o uso delle
trappole quei cartellini colorati che
vedete nella fotografia o costruisco
addirittura una serra sopra le mie
piante in modo da proteggere copro la
serra con una rete
antinsetto talvolta tutto questo però in
agricoltura biologica non è ancora
sufficiente a difendere completamente le
colture quindi perdo qualcosa della mia
produzione
tutte queste strategie che da un lato ci
dicono difendiamo rispettiamo l'ambiente
indovinate un po costano e costano molto
di più di un trattamento insetticida
volendo sintetizzare
questo concetto fare qualità produrre
qualcosa di qualità ortaggi compresi
costa talvolta costa molto l'agricoltura
qualunque sia l'approccio che prenda in
considerazione biologico un approccio
intensivo convenzionale alta tecnologia
come vedremo più tardi in altri speech
deve e può puntare a ottenere prodotti
di qualità deve e può puntare ad essere
sostenibile a non impattare con
l'ambiente con l'ambiente naturale però
da quello che vi ho detto
la vita per gli agricoltori non è poi
così semplice e sempre come dire presi
tra il dover effettuare delle scelte
corrette che permettano da un lato di
far quadrare il bilancio dall'altro di
ottenere prodotti di qualità o diventare
sempre più sostenibili anche per il
consumatore le cose non sono proprio
lineari da un lato il massimo sconto il
prezzo più basso dall'altro la necessità
o la voglia di pagare il giusto per un
prodotto che sia di qualità è un
prodotto che sia sostenibile
credo che la soluzione una parte della
soluzione possa essere sempre nel fare
delle scelte che siano di base delle
scelte etiche
consapevoli ed etiche che quindi se da
un lato portino a richiedere sempre di
più rispetto dell'ambiente sostenibilità
delle aziende dei prodotti dall'altro
non possono esimersi da riconoscere il
giusto prezzo giusto costo di quello che
vuol dire ottenere un prodotto
sostenibile e che rispetti l'ambiente mi
fa piacere salutarvi questa sera
sperando che da domani ho da dopo da
quando usciamo da qui tutti quanti
diventiamo un po più attori della
sostenibilità pagando anche il giusto
prezzo per i prodotti di qualità facendo
scelte consapevoli ed eccole ed eque e
ed etiche ma soprattutto facendo scelte
sostenibili grazie mille
[Applauso]